[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous 20h44 on est en
direct c'est touche pas mon poste juste
après touche pas mon poste bien sûr
meville en quête dans une tassau il est
très très fort ce mon V là je que c'est
vrai c'est vrai les chér dans le people
on va recevoir bertr pasuto bertr est
incroyable Bernard d'ailleurs bcut
Bernard TR les
émissions je P un mec qui s'appelle
berir Patrice vous allez
voir on va recevoir
non non on vaevoir Bernard
passut P c'est je l'adore mais jeadore
oui comme vous avz pas prénom Bernard
pascut son livre est incroyable les
héritiers je vous le dire lui connais
tout sur les héritages Claude François
Johnny ALID jacqu brelle Lilian Boncour
Jean-Luc de laarue connait tous les
secrets il va nous le dévoiler ce soir
et depuis quelques mois il enquête
également sur Alain Delon et ouais les
gars et ouais il va nous donner toutes
les dernières infos sur ce dernier et on
va pas faire le point P en fait par
qu'on va être un petit peu short les
chéies je vous le dis voilà on fera
demain les vont pas bouger voilà donc
demand àam d'aller prendre un verre en
face mais j'adoreiam bien je l'embrasse
sielle veut venir sinon comme ça pour
repasser une tête c'est la bienvenue
regardez pour venir
m'embrasser ces dernières semaines les
enfants d'Ain Delon se déchire par
interview interposé sur fond d'héritage
ma sœur elle a 50% mon frère et moi donc
on a
25% car après que la star a été victime
d'un AVC en 2019 son état de santé fait
aujourd'hui beaucoup parler et
puisquealin Delon pourrait laisser
derrière lui une importante fortune il y
aurait 320 330 millions d'euros tandis
que certaines célébrités n'ont pas
hésité à déshériter leurs enfants
l'héritage des stars est souvent source
de conflit à l'instar de la famille de
Johnny hidday qui s'est livré une
véritable bataille juridique c'est une
période très très compliquée pour moi et
ma famille révélation exclusive sur
l'affaire de long et sur les héritages
de vos stars préférés ce soir dans
[Musique]
TPMP merci Bernard pascuto je connais
très bien votre cousin Bertrand merci
merci d'être là alors vous avez fait
bien sûr
jeunialidé béan courourt montant Claude
François et en ce moment c'est vrai que
les héritages on parle énormément de
l'affaire de long que vous
traitez que vous avez vous avez enquêté
dessus est-ce que vous avez récemment
rencontré iromi parce qu'on comprend
rien sur iromi sur sur ce qui se passe
et cetera iromi c'était quoi en fait à
la
base iromi d'après ce qu'elle me dit
puisque je l'ai rencontré assez
longuement à plusieurs reprises euh et
d'après ce qu'elle dit ça semble étayé
elle était la compagne d'Alain Delon
depuis 2006 et elle le connaît depuis 32
ans et ils ont eu une me dit-elle une
relation amoureuse qui est d'ailleurs
matérialisée par des photos
euh de couple posé euh et il y avait
même d'ailleurs des des des photos qui
devaient sortir euh au moment juste
avant son expulsion euh et voilà donc
c'est ce qu'elle dit c'est que voilà
elle a toujours eu une relation euh euh
amoureuse avec Delon et qui s'est
transformé dans les dernières années
depuis le WC euh en une relation de
protection aussi parce que il fallait
s'occuper de lui voilà Gilles tu tu
confirme un petit peu les infos bah en
tout cas euh c'est pas ce que disent les
enfants j'ai pas dit que c'était ce que
disaient les enfants mais la la thèse de
la relation amoureuse est contestée elle
elle dit effectivement qu'on lui avait
presque promis le mariage et cetera une
vie matrimoniale ce que les enfants
dénoncent comme étant un abus de
confiance voilà il y a deux thèses
antagonistes sinon il y aurait pas il y
aurait pas de souci he absolument voilà
alors mais ce qu'elle dit n'est pas
forcément vrai ah mais j'ai jamais dit
que c'était vrai j'ai dit ce qu'elle me
disait absolument c'est ça voilà il y a
quand même des photos et des qu'est-ce
qui t'arrive non non pas du tout j'
essayé de donner deux versions elle a
vraiment été là la
compagne la compagne d'Alain Delon ou
seulement la dame de compagnie euh je je
suis certain qu'elle a été la la la
compagne de d' Delon d'ailleurs d'autant
plus que contrairement à ce que disent
ses enfants euh dans Paris Match
notamment en 2020 1 an après son WC il
fait un titre dans une interview de
Cyril Viguier euh c'est entre guillemets
àin Delon c'est grâce à iromi que je
m'en suis sorti elle est formidable il
parle de ça compagne il parle lui de sa
compagne elle pense quoi de la guerre
entre les enfants pourquoi elle pense
quoi de la guerre entre les enfants
alors il y a c'est vous avez évoqué
l'affaire du mariage alors le le mariage
ça a é ça a été prévu à un moment
donné je suis pas sûr que ce soit allé
très loin euh je sais que parce que
iromi est une une femme qui est assez
sensé et qui euh j'ai sentis qu'elle
racontait pas n'importe quoi par exemple
cette de mari elle m'a dit que c'était
elle qui en avait parlé qui en avait
parlé à DEL long euh parce qu'elle avait
besoin d'être protégé euh voilà elle m'a
dit que à plusieurs reprises elle avait
dit à Deon euh il faut que tu me
protèges si tarrive si tarrive quelque
chose un jour j'ai aucune protection euh
et euh voilà donc l'idée du mariage euh
voilà je je pense que c'est l'affaire du
l'affaire du mariage ce projet de
mariage qui a qui a déclenché beaucoup
de choses c'est ça he euh absolument
absolument c'est c'est c'est lorsque a
été évoqué d'abord le mot compagne vous
l'avez dit et puis le mariage que tout
s'est déclenché mais quand Alain Delon
dit ma compagne c'est très contesté
puisqu'on dit qu'il pouvait être sous
son influence et quand elle parle de
mariage là vous êtes en train d'épouser
sa thèse monsieur vous avez dit selon
moi il y avait vra tuataquer à chaque
fois qu'il dit quelque
chose laisse tranquille bernardou je
respecte éminemment mais vous épousez la
tess d'iromi Rolin c'est vot Alain Delon
il met une main sur une compagnie de
manière un pe
licite dame de compag moi je pense que
ça les a bien arrangé les trois enfants
que ce soit elle qui s'occupe surtout
après les AVC de d'Alain Delon et que
quand ils ont senti que ça pouvait aller
trop loin et que ça pouvait interférer
sur l'héritage c'est là qu'ils l'ont
jeté dehors moi c'est ma version vous
avez tout compris vous devriez lui
expliquer hein parce que vous avez tout
compris les enfants venaient quand même
très peu à
Douch voilà il y avait quelqu'un qui
s'en occupait on voit d'ailleurs
depuis en 6 mois comment on nous a
décrit Alain Delon sequestré à l'époque
et moi je m'aperçois que Anad Deon avant
il parlait il
apparaissait aujourd'hui depuis depuis
le mois de juillet il y a plus d'un
Deon c'est étonant alors les dernières
infos Gill sur l'affaire de les
dernières infos c'est qu'il y a donc une
expertise médicale qui a eu lieu samedi
je crois et que Anthony a immédiatement
contesté cette expertise médicale selon
lui le médecin n'est pas un médecin
expert et surtout selon lui au moment de
cette expertise qui avait été diligenté
par le parquet de Montargis Anouka était
présente donc Anthony dit ce ne sont pas
les réponses d'Alain Delon de mon père
ce sont les réponses d'anouka qui lui
sont dictés et cetera donc en fait cette
expertise médicale qui devait permettre
d'avoir une certitude sur l'état de
santé d'Alain Delon ça repart en
cacophonie et en extrême confusion on ne
sait pas si réellement cette expertise
de un verdict alors justement pourquoi
Anouka va avoir plus que ses frères
Bernard pourquoi Anouka va avoir plus
que ses frères ça je pense que an Deon
l'a expliqué encore une fois quand je
parle quand je cite des gens c'est pas
moi qui prend parti j'entends monsieur
parce que tout à l'heure vous avez bien
raison parce qu'il vousueule à chaque
fois donc c'est g Verdez il est comme ça
il il m'a déjà embêté il y a plusieurs
années sure sur un livre sur des champs
sur
football il
exc-o ant il y a pas que moi qui va vous
embêter attention ah oui c'est un très
très bon ami à moi ou oui oui mais c'est
très bien ah
merde des chants pardon alors parlons
pas de ça c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
mon ami je l'aime beaucoup et j'ai
beaucoup d'estime pour lui c'est c'est
c'est quelqu'un je l'aime énormément et
donc c'est vraiment un ami je déteste
qu'on touche à mes amis donc reparlons
de Alain Delon
euh qui n'est pas votre ami si non je
l'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup alinon
ah si si mais non mais al il y on dit
rien on dit rien de mal de sur lui sur
de voilà alors donc Anouk va avoir plus
que ses frères euh c'est pourquoi en
fait ben pourquoi parce que vous savez
dans le dans dans les règles de
succession c'est que quand on a trois
enfants par exemple que c'est le cas de
long qu'on est pas marié on doit donner
75 % à ces enfants donc c'est 25 %
chacun puisqu'ils sont trois après reste
ce qu'on appelle la quotité disponible
c'est-à-dire c'est la somme d'argent
dont vous pouvez user comme il vous
semble bon voilà et donc il aurait pu
dire je vais donner à mon chauffeur des
uvres à iromi à la SPA voilà bon lui il
a décidé de donner ses 25 % il en a
parfaitement le droit supplémentaire à
un ouchka alors le pourquoi je veux dire
cet homme a montré depuis des années et
des années qu'il était qu'il était fou
amoureux de sa fille qu'il vend euh qu'
dont il a fait son exécutrice
testamentaire d'ailleurs euh voilà au
détriment des garçons maintenant si vous
me donnez me demander mon avis là-dessus
je trouve que ça n'est pas bien euh
parce que voilà moi je ne ferai jamais
ça avec mes enfants mais il a encore une
fois c'est parfaitement légal est-ce que
iromie était au courant de ce plan de
succession est-ce qu'elle vous l'a dit
ah mais tout le monde tout le monde est
au courant parce que c'est c'est pas un
secret depuis longtemps de de long là
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a permis au
Delon il y a plusieurs mois de de de
dire je ça me fait rire que eux ils
allaient pas faire la même chose que les
alidé ouais et en fait en moyen moyen en
quoi ils ont fait ils ont ils ont fait
100 fois pire quoi ouais euh donc on l'a
vu al a le droit de ne pas donner la
même somme à tout le monde oui Valérie
vous poser une question non merci oui CH
Oui moi ce que je voulais savoir c'est
que par rapport à iromir Rin que vous
connaissez très bien estce qu'elle
est-ce qu'elle elle pense que les trois
enfants sont ligués contre elle est-ce
qu'elle pense que il y a réellement un
problème entre les enfants ou est-ce
qu'elle pense être la victime d'un
complot familial en quelque sorte quel
est son son sentiment est-ce qu'elle est
amère
aujourd'hui c'est une femme qui est qui
est blessée parce qu'elle a été expulsée
Manu militar tout le monde a vu c'était
quand même c'est quand même assez
horrible quoi
bon est tombé dans un piège elle s'est
retrouvé en jean et t-shirt avec 70 €
sur elle rien d'autre elle n'a toujours
pas récupéré ni la majeure partie de ses
effets ni l'argent qu'elle avait à
l'intérieur alors que la plainte déposée
par les enfants a été classée sans suite
la sienne aussi monsieur pardon la
sienne aussi pourquoi tu es toujours
agressif il est toujours
agressifable pas l'avocatom Bernard
c'est insupportable dit-lui qu'il est
agressif non la plainte diomy Rolin
était classée sensible et c'est pas de
ça dont on parle par fait pas pu
récupérer ses affaires ses effets son
argent euh alors que la sa plate a été
classée son suite on lu reprocher voilà
après hom mirolin pour le pour le pour
la suite je
laisse je laisse la parole à son avocat
parce que elle elle va elle poursuit
aussi en justice et j'ai même j'ai même
lu j'aiétéis un peu surpris samedi euh
que elle attaqué les enfants de long
pour tentative domic volontaire alors
celle-là je l'avais encore jamais vu
contre
elle les dernières infos Gill c'est que
le témoignage du médecin traitant aussi
a eu le témoignage du médecin traitant
le Suisse oui c'est dernier message oui
le professeur glaçon oui oui oui le
professeur glaçon lui il dit absolument
en Suisse il veut absolument reprendre
le traitement il dit que il dit qu'alin
Delon est extrêmement menacé pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout le médecin
traitant d'alin Delon a
dit il dit était bien au courant de
l'arrêt du traitement de son père elle y
aurait même consenti elle a accepté
l'arrêt d'un certain médicament alors
qu'à moi elle dit le contraire elle m'a
dit que c'était ses frères qui avait
pris la décision et qu'elle n'était pas
au courant alors qu'elle l'était c'est
c'est c'est une
info c'est la suite des SMS que vous
avez
dévoiler c'est la suite de votre scoop
de vendredi qui a fait énormément bouger
l'affaire effectivement où on
sous-entendait dans les SMS kanouka
avait en quelque sorte légitimé l'arrêt
du traitement qu'elle conteste voilà là
qui parle pardon qui parle là c'est le
médecin traitant d'alin Deon c'est
marqué derrière vous Cyril c'est le
médecin traitant d'alin Deon je ne pense
pas que ce soit monsieur glaçon oui non
monsieur Mister Freeze
alors
excuseo très bien euh iromi elle elle
est pas du tout dans le dans
l'héritage zéro quoi il a pas pour le
moment enfin je veux dire on peut s'en
tenir à ce qu'on sait à savoir 75 % pour
les enfants plus 25 % à à Anouchka ça
fait 100 % ouis et donc elle a 50 % euh
après euh oui enfin ce qu'on ce qu'on
remarque surtout c'est que c'est quand
même assez confus les enfants se tirent
dessus entre eux s'attaquent
mutuellement se dénonc et moi je
remarque modestement que ils ont été
unis qu'à un qu'à un seul moment c'est
au mois de juillet pour virer iromi
exactement une fois que l'ennemi a été a
été abattu euh maintenant on s'entretue
exactement merci en tout cas merci
d'avoir été avec nous Bernard pascuto
faudrait que vous reveniez nous voir
pour les autres affaires parce que c'est
extrêmement intéressant votre livre on
va passer à Patrick 37